oh oh my goodness nemo are you okay
you might know everything about your
favorite pixar characters
every line every lyric and every dance
move but what about the voices behind
them
have you ever wondered if the pixar
characters you love the most are
actually being voiced by real life
actors
and not just that but huge celebrities
well
we're right there with you and you might
be totally surprised to find out who the
voices responsible for our animated
faves really are
hey champ where'd all your friends go
pixar's newest soon-to-be animated
classic
is soul one of the most heartwarming
toe-tapping
totally wonderful movies to come out in
a long time the film stars none other
than jamie foxx as joe
a high school band teacher with a love
for jazz this is where it all started
this is the moment where i fell in love
with jazz
alongside fox is the hilariously
talented tina fey who plays 22 and
angela bassett
a legendary actress who you might know
most recently for playing the voodoo
queen
and other roles in american horror story
but that ain't you
sis inside out is definitely one of the
best pixar movies to come out in a long
time
even though it made us uglycry for hours
after the credits finish rolling
the film all about the feelings that
exist inside of all of us at all times
was a huge hit
definitely due to the amazing cast of
voices they had behind every role
amy poehler led the pack as joy and was
the perfectly bubbly person to bring the
character to life
alongside polar was mindy kaling as
disgust and phyllis smith from the
office as sadness
yeah find the fun i don't know how to do
that
when we found out that chris pratt and
tom holland would be teaming up
outside of the marvel universe we
couldn't have been more excited
pratt and holland star as two 11 year
old brothers who go on an epic adventure
to resurrect their father
but only for one day it's a heartwarming
story
and the two movie stars are awesome
playing off one another
command it i am commanding it i'm just
clearly not good at this it also
features academy award winner octavia
spencer as the manticore
this tabard is
we loved the original incredibles so
much we actually couldn't believe that
it could get any better
but with the incredibles 2 somehow it
did
of course they had to bring back the
original family cast to reprise their
roles which includes the amazing holly
hunter and craig t
nelson as bob and helen parr they also
had no choice but to bring back samuel l
jackson as frozone
and for the sequel they added some
awesome new characters
like void voiced by none other than
sophia bush
i just want to thank you for like for
being you
when brave came along we fell in love
with its heroine
merida i am merida merida was no disney
princess
this scottish warrior didn't need a
prince to do anything for her
and she had the best hair of all of them
merida was voiced by scottish actress
kelly mcdonald
who you might recognize as none other
than helena ravenclaw herself
from harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 2. i cannot help you
when we first met dory the blue fish
with a short-term memory problem in
finding nemo
we were totally won over problem buddy
huh huh do you do you for finding dory
pixar had no choice but to bring back
the hilarious ellen degeneres to reprise
her iconic role but they also added a
ton of new voices
including not one but two modern family
alumni
both ed o'neill and ty burrell joined
the cast along with the legendary diane
keaton
and we know you'll never forget us
when it came to choosing the voices to
bring the characters to life
the crew spared no expense in bringing
on some of the funniest people around
patton oswalt leads the cast as remy the
rat alongside the hilarious janine
garofalo as colette
and none other than lego batman himself
will arnett
as horst i killed a man with this
dumb up isn't the same kind of
star-studded movie as we've talked about
before
like the incredibles or inside out but
when it comes to the voice of the
precocious little boy scout with many
badges
russell that doesn't matter russell
quickly works his way into our
and eventually carl's heart and the
directors really didn't want to cast a
kid who sounded too much like a trained
actor for this part
so they went with the adorable jordan a
guy and the rest is history
i'll give the food for him i'll walk him
i'll change his newspapers
when he was only 13 years old child
actor anthony gonzalez won the role of
miguel
in this incredibly heartwarming and
musical movie and he totally holds his
own
even when working against huge latino
stars like benjamin bratt and gayle
garcia bernal
musician team musician i need a favor to
give us a little look into the lives of
our favorite scare artists before they
became famous
pixar brought back the iconic voices of
john goodman and billy crystal to
reprise their roles as sully and mike
james b sullivan mike wazowski
but they also added a handful of the
funniest people out there
including aubry plaza john krasinski
nathan fillion and sean hayes
i'm a dance major and i'm not toy story
was pixar's first ever movie
and their first huge hit it was so
successful that it spawned four sequels
and each one was somehow more amazing
than the last and there wasn't an
actor out there who didn't want to be
part of the beloved series when it came
to number four
the cast includes none other than keanu
reeves as duke kaboom
ali maki as giggles mcdimples keegan
michael key and jordan peele as ducky
and bunny
i am buzz lightyear space ranger
the third movie in the cars franchise
was able to bring in a whole group of
brand new celebs to lend voices to some
of their new characters
along with bringing back the infamous
voice of owen wilson to reprise his
role as the red racing car lightning
mcqueen they added
army hammer's notorious baritone to the
mix as jackson's storm
you have no idea what a pleasure it is
for me to finally beat you
and the gorgeous kerry washington as
natalie certain to round out the already
star-studded cast
the racing world is changing the good
dinosaur might not have been a super
smash hit like toy story or monsters inc
but this heartwarming story about an
unlikely friendship between an
apothesaurus named arlo
and a young human named spot actually
features a couple of oscar winners
anna paquin stars alongside frances
mcdormand and if you listen closely you
might hear the famously rumbling voice
of sam elliott
you can't get rid of fear it's like
mother nature
while most of the dialogue in wall-e
takes place in one-word exchanges
between
wally and eva
there are actually actors behind our two
favorite robots
and of course they had to add in a few
famous faces
uh voices sigourney weaver came on to
provide the soothing voice of the ship's
computer
your day is very important to us and the
adorable comedy legend fred willard
signed on to play shelby forthright see
you back home real soon
along with canadian comedy star dave
foley as skip
the film featured the talents of julia
louise dreyfus and a very
adorable and very young hayden
panettieri as princess dot
but not just that making her big screen
debut
long before she would become a bonafide
disney star ashley tisdale secured a
part in a bug's life
as the lead blueberry scout
freedom did you know that toy story was
the first movie ever to feature entirely
computer-generated animation
it really was the first of its kind and
pixar knew they had struck gold
especially with a cast that includes
legends like tom hanks as woody and tim
allen as buzz
lightyear leading the pack and you my
friend are responsible for delaying my
rendezvous with star command
while we already mentioned that owen
wilson gave voice to the beloved race
car lightning mcqueen
the car's movie just wouldn't be the
same without larry the cable guy shoot
i was in charge of hunting him down if
he tried to escape the beloved comedian
voiced the role of mater
the hilarious and lovable tow truck with
the two giant front teeth
i don't know i got nothing i guess i
ain't dark when it comes to that
even though some voice actors might not
become household names
that doesn't mean that their voices
don't hold a special place in our hearts
these two actresses definitely fit that
criteria the first is mary gibbs
who was only three years old when she
recorded this beloved character
and secondly we have the unmistakable
voice of jennifer tilly who plays mike's
girlfriend celia
i'm thinking about getting it cut and
who can be seen as bonnie swanson on
family guy
oh my goodness how did that get in there
did we miss your favorite pixar
character of all time
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to hit subscribe to keep up with
the latest from the things
you